you know after your whole experience
through you know being incarcerated and
accusations and everything do you
where does do you have like who do you
who you blame the most do you feel like
[Music]
Congrats wedding date isn't yet right
yeah I saw the meteor man who Nicole oh
you did yeah I really inspired me that
was a production that Chris manufactured
on a Sunday when I was the most
unsuspecting like you could tell I was
the most unsuspecting because I was in
my pajamas I was sewing a wizard cloak
like I was down on that floor and to
like hear this like missile said sounded
like a missile to me that he like he
rigged up our entire house in our entire
backyard with you know secret speakers
and like lights so that when I came down
he like dug a fog machine like
underground underneath the meteorite so
that it was smoking yeah and it's it's
great like he had this thing really you
should ask Kristin honey but like he
hadn't like manufactured this whole
thing for he was working on it with his
brother for a year
oh wow so like and then just one day he
was like today's the day and so he made
the rounds and like brought champagne to
my parents and then while I was like he
was running errands while I was sewing
my cloak and Disney running errands so
in my cloak it's like a like a deleted
scene from Shrek we go to plenty of
Renaissance Fairs in fact we even out
Renaissance Faire or Renaissance Faire
once really yes and ran fairs I'm gonna
throw out the term because people don't
know I've been to a few I'm an economist
according to some I want to almost a
misdemeanor crimes and a few of them by
people call them Ren fairs right yes
okay good yeah I like to use that term
when I can sure yeah no I'm his brother
Chris's brother is a professional night
mm-hmm
like he runs the Seattle nights where
they do jousting and Cory act like
choreographed fight scenes and they get
hired by Ren fairs to put on shows so
where they're doing the jousting in the
fighting and are using actual swords and
actual armor so whenever we go to a
Renaissance Faire we get hooked up with
their gear oh we can out yeah we can
read fair absolutely we we have 100%
like full access Ren Faire and this one
time we went to so if so people are
wondering what's going on with Amanda
Knox she has backstage passes at a
Renaissance Faire yes
yeah I can tell you goings on yeah
recent engagement that kind of like puts
like it kind of puts a nice charm into
your life okay yes Oh God um yeah this
is the stuff that people don't know
about me people think they know a lot of
things about me but really I'm just a
nerd who likes to wear costumes to go to
Ren Faire
now right affairs I feel like Ren Faire
is kind of you are they is their arch
rival kind of like a carnival like the
small town carny folk I feel like those
people probably I could see him kind of
getting into some fisticuffs at night or
something you know you know I know
there's some crossover I do know that
some performers who come to Renaissance
Fairs do perform at carnivals as well
like there was this one amazing woman
who trained a bunch of rats to like do
acrobatics with her oh yeah which was
great and she was awesome and she goes
to the rent fairs and the carnivals
carnivals I wish I don't know I I feel
like carnivals just make me feel sick I
don't know I'm it's a little seed here
they get you hopped up on the sugar then
they can shake you up with the Machine
yeah it's very it's a lot more
adrenaline rush than I think I can
handle I just tend to feel a little
nauseated yeah
so I don't go to carnivals very often so
Ren fairs yeah I would say yeah Ren
Faire is almost like a carnival - the
nausea yes there's more and more
playfulness because you're like you go
and you're not exactly in character but
you're playing pretend like everyone's
just kind of playing pretend with each
other and they're getting their hair
braided so they can look more
Renaissance EE and yeah like the idea is
to just sort of like let your inner
nerve
embrace itself yeah and like there is
you know these are some places where
like it's the one place that somebody
feels at home like the you know to be
nerdy in the world like yeah you can be
a cool nerd in this world but not
everyone's a cool nerd some people are
just straight up nurse yeah
and like when you are allow yourself to
get into costume and just like just nerd
out and it's so sweet and so fun I love
it yeah it's kind of like you see people
like yeah you'll see like like a fair
maid in there you'll see like a lot of
wooden swords you you hear a lot about
corset gasm oh yeah oh really some big
that's the place to let them on display
in Minnesota has a lot of big ones too I
know that yeah I've heard about them
I've never actually been to those before
but I think me and Chris are going to be
going with his brother and wife and
their best friend they all do run fair
stuff together I think we're gonna be
going down this big one in Texas in
November
I'm really excited apparently it is like
10 times as big as any of them that our
hearing in Washington Staton's day yeah
so it's just like a world took an
alternate reality to explore while
wearing dope costumes yeah yeah and
peaceful more peaceful times I think in
a way maybe I wanna but they had dragons
back then maybe wish dragons they really
do yeah that's it yeah I mean it depends
on them it depends on the Farex is still
affair like you know there's still gonna
be some fair food I don't know I find it
really exciting I think that I love
watching his brother do his thing yeah I
like doing like they are swinging real
swords at each other and occasionally
like he'll get like a sharp elbow to to
the face and ha like his face cut open
and it's like this this is real yeah the
only difference is no one's actually
trying to kill each other right look
like they are and occasionally someone
gets hurt yeah yeah Ren fairs you know I
went when I was actually I went a couple
years ago I'll be honest you know I'm
trying to lie about it but I went a few
years ago and uh and it was uh what was
it like oh it started raining so
suddenly like behind
seemed like everything kind of became
like the the world's kind of got mixed
because everybody's trying to stay dry
so you had a lot of people that weren't
like in you know in like Ren garb like
trying to get into the rent holes and
stuff got a little shelter became it was
a commodity well yeah especially because
a lot of these fairs are end up being
sort of put out into these fields yeah
yeah all the water just accumulates in
these fields and like the Ren Faire that
I go to in Washington State very often
like you know it's there and then like
it has to disappear at the end of the
Ren Faire and then that that field gets
recycled into something else and I've
used it before to do a mud run to be
like an obstacle like mud course so
that's like the week after Ren Faire
it's mud it's not running like crazy I
wonder what the field thinks I wonder
the fields like who's on my back this
week yeah I know thankfully the Ren
Faire they're pretty home yeah that it
sees mud freaks and then the mud Peaks
were like chugging beer and like getting
really dirty and that's also a great use
of random grass field yeah yeah that's
interesting yeah the one that I went to
was way out in the middle of nowhere and
we went when I was in school I was in
like a special class and so they would
take us out there and one time they're
like okay you have to dress up and I was
I didn't understand the concept
innocence fairs and I was on Peter Pan
that were so it worked but it was uh you
were in the kind of right time period in
terms of fairy tale like that totally
they have they have like Robin Hood
themed renfe that's who I think I'm
meant to be was Robin who are not as
messed up you know
and my whole costume winning so it was
all just tie it was like a bunch of
stuff and then I wrap myself in fishing
twine right to hold it all together so
it was way bizarre I'm having trouble
visualizing this but I do you have
pictures uh I think there's some
drawings or sketches okay but it was
definitely kind of a CG look they were
pretty much the same thing Robin Hood
and Peter Pan
yeah totally you're fine as long as you
have the tunic the green tunic you fit
in I think I got offended though when
people called me Robin Hood that was my
problem
oh you're
and that Roz's Peter yeah that's a
really yeah the way I interacted with
the world there you know kind of bought
I think a bad attitude as well it could
have been the twine to it was 30 pound
test and it was really really tight you
know there are people walking around in
chain mail and like legit farmer out
there though like 90 pounds of crap in
90 degree weather oh yeah I saw a guy
drinking wd-40 out there one day and I
was like Oh or me just so much Mead oh
yeah that's beer right well it's it's
very sugary I think it's more like wine
but like extremely sugary mmm it's like
honey it's like it tends to have like a
honey flavor like a portent almost or
something yeah yeah um and people get
shit-faced on that meat uh that's um
lean to I think it's gotten a little bit
urban and sometimes when it's dark
enough things are getting strange thanks
for coming in thank you for having me I
really I I admit that I have I had not
heard your podcast before but my what
convinced me to come on is one of my
best friends said that yours is the best
podcast ever and she has the biggest
crush on you
so case you want to like meet someone
who's also amazing she you know she
moved over all the way to Italy to like
be supportive of me and visit me in
prison like she's an incredible person
and she has a big fat crush on you oh
dang
and she's ex-mormon which I find that
ex-mormons are the best people ever yeah
yeah I've heard some things about I mean
they're uh yeah Mormons are really
really unique when I like one time I was
walking through the Mormon place in Utah
like in Park City the big yeah the
temple yeah you're not a temple yeah but
the tabernacle and we had like they had
like 19 weddings going on like I was in
there like for ceremony just on accident
oh just like just like I accidentally
just would just walk in different paths
wow you got lucky I've been there before
multiple times and
I've never seen a wedding there I've
only I've only wished like I've walked
into that tabernacle and like I wish
someone was singing here because they do
they're incredible singers they're
incredible musicians and they have a
really great sense of community they're
really supportive of each other and you
know then there's all the crazy doc Matt
but like yeah there's a lot of rough
don't move everything like I feel like
these days you hear more about the dogma
so much of everything than you do about
like the good stuff like the humanity
yes no that's my big issue is like I'm
constantly coming face to face with
different kinds of dogmas and they don't
have to be established dogmas they can
be like the whole vilification narrative
is something that I find it's like well
we've decided that somebody is a monster
and now what and for me you know I feel
like my job now in the world it having
been mischaracterized as a as a monster
but also having like lived next to
people who have been imprisoned for
years for things that they actually did
do is be like well it's a lot more
complicated people are people and the
reason they do things are not for
monstrous reasons most of the time it's
usually a human reason and we don't like
to I find that the greater society tends
to not want to embrace those human
qualities they want to have a scapegoat
they want to like hold someone up as a
symbol and say this is something that we
can hate do you think that it's a
greater society that because I I find
that it appears that way certainly like
through the news and through media for
sure but I person a person I find that
it's not that do you know what I'm
talking about country sure sure sure
totally um and I'm not disagreeing with
you I'm just saying it's interesting
that yeah like as a as a mass as a
especially like if you like both like do
with the news and media it's like yes
it's like let's put a pin in this this
is you know we want yeah we need like an
angel we need a devil we need you know
we need figures you know to get people
excited and to get them engaged but then
when you go to humans it seems like
there is more of a care about the people
a lot of times or there is there is more
empathy than you get through the nail
that's in the news yes I think that on a
person-to-person basis the instinct that
another human being is across from you
and your you automatically empathize
with them because they have eyes and
they have a nose and they have a mouth
and they look like you because they're a
human like that instinct kicks in but
there's another instinct that we all
have which is to stop thinking and you
know we're like we're god I think it was
all right have you read a lot of
Jonathan hate mm-hmm I think you would
like him he talks about like the reasons
why people come into conflict with each
other despite the fact that you know
they're all good people and they're all
thinking people and feeling people and
one of the reasons is like you know
we're we're like 80% chimp and like 20%
bee and like the be part of us sort of
like latches on to a group and then just
agrees with everything in that group and
other eyes is anyone outside of that and
so I I'm finding it interesting I don't
know what from your experience like how
many people have to come together into a
group before they start thinking like a
group as opposed to that like an
individual who sees another human being
across from them have you noticed that
like have you you know I've been amazed
at just like through podcasting and
stuff like the amount of people that are
good in the world that's what I find
just by going out and doing comedy shows
and having people come out to them but
just good people like I've just been
amazed it's really kind of changed a
little bit of my perception sometimes I
think of of the of the world especially
like through the news you know in like
the mainstream media like I mean I feel
like that got so spoiled like it's
always bad news it's always bad and now
it's gotten to the point where I think
but I think most people do not believe
it anymore I think that most people
realize that it's bad and they know that
they're being that it's a trick or that
it's a you know and I hate to say that
you know your experience there's
probably a lot of experiences over the
past 25 years that were like paramount
to probably people realizing that why
this is there's no value here of me
giving myself to this anymore because
they don't even care like what's what's
real like I have more empathy than this
news
so at a certain point I'm not if I keep
taking it in and believing it then I'm
I'm doing almost a disservice to my to
Who I am as a as a person yeah and I
think that's a fair point I also think
though that we're sort of teaching
ourselves how to think less thoroughly
just by like the way that we're
consuming a lot of information a lot of
them a lot of information is coming our
way and like flashing across our eyes
yeah and like triggering an emotional
response and then that emotional
response happens then it's gone and we
stop thinking about it
and I think we are I don't know I get I
get both sides of it and just you know
even from personal experience getting
both sides of it where on the one hand
we have we have such a hunger for like
depth and human connection and that's
why a lot of the media is responding to
that and trying to create these
difficult you know gray space narratives
and on the other hand we have also an
outrage culture and both of those are
real yeah and and like the the flippancy
with which the casualness with which we
decide oh I hate that person or oh that
person's worthless or oh like it's just
it's so quick yeah is it two different
offices that almost you feel like
sometimes like there's a me that's that
like will react to something like
through through television or through
online and and and make a choice you
know pass a judgement and then there's a
me that's and that me almost doesn't
even seem real I feel like that's the
same me that would engage with like um
like flirting with women online and that
sort of stuff sometimes where it's like
it feels almost like a video game of not
real life I wish I knew that what that
was like I'm I'm not
I mean it's it's fascinating like I
obviously can't date online so I haven't
had that experience but I've definitely
I mean lots of people our age are doing
online dating and are experiencing each
other in a very different way like it's
not like you run across them and you see
them in context in it in us in an
element interacting with people what you
do is you read their profile and find
out what
their interests are and if you have the
same interest maybe that means that
you'll get along but I don't know you
can have completely different interests
and actually get along and that's when
the real connection yeah I think
connection I think overall it seems like
connection is just a thing that it's
almost like I wonder if it'll be like in
a museum at some point like it's funny I
was talking to my niece a couple of
months ago and I was talking about
imagination and she thought it was an
app she hadn't heard of it
Oh sweetheart and she's very smart and
very capable and but it was just very
bizarre to me yeah is there an app for
that
yeah can i outsource I don't think I
heard that she's like I don't think my
mom lets me I think gets under parental
controls she said that she doesn't know
if I'm like no no no it's just inside of
you you know it's like this thing that
yeah let's do it right now that's not
tell your mom it's your own it's like
one of your few ask you know do you have
like you know after your whole
experience through you know being
incarcerated and accusations and
everything do you where does do you have
like who do you who do you blame the
most do you feel like oh I think you
might be surprised that you know as much
as like the blame game was happening at
me I don't really think of it in terms
of blame you know I don't I I had a long
time to like sit in my cell and wonder
why this was happening to me and you
know that's still a question that
bothers me like just why me why me of
all people in the world to have this
happen to them why I don't have a
sufficient answer for that but I don't
think that it's a specific person that I
feel the need to blame I think human
beings fail to see each other all the
time
every day and it's not like it's
someone's fault you know I'm trying to
like one thing that I'm doing right now
is I'm trying to reach out to my
Secutor because you know the the easy
and automatic response to any of these
situations is to be like [ __ ] that guy
he's a bad dude and he did something bad
to me right but I've never found that to
be a very satisfactory answer to why it
doesn't answer my why question uh yeah
you know like it gives you like kind of
a like a cane a little bit but it
doesn't really give you like a real
place to stay and kind of yeah and I
don't know if it's just my disposition
but I don't like lashing out does not
feel satisfactory like doesn't satisfy
me in any way possible I think I
remember like one time wanting to like
punch a pillow once and I was just like
oh and it was like for some stupid thing
like maybe like traffic or something and
and I was like oh that's what everyone's
feeling all the time wanting to like
punch something like now I know what
that feels like
I don't know I I it was there like it
but I I guess I mean also like in a
sense of like was there a group that or
and not even a specific group or person
but was it more like the the country was
it more the was it more the the media
what was it the news was it the the
police there that that was the thing
that you're like they it seems like they
were the ones that kept the ball rolling
because it seemed bizarre that you were
going through all this I think from you
know I consider myself just kind of an
everyman it seemed like like you didn't
seem like somebody that would kill
someone to me easily and even with it
with the information from the case but
you but you'd probably displayed
behaviors where I was like oh if I think
you know she seems like someone that's a
you know unique or aloof or whimsical
and I could see that kind of fitting
like obviously a wild story
um but was it more the media that kept
you that do you think one of them
influenced more the fact that you were
you were stuck there for so long that
you had to go through all of this do you
think I think that
it's like everything it's a lot more
complicated than it would be nice if it
worked because it's a combination of
factors it's a combination of the law
and like what what was legally a lot
what the police were legally allowed to
do with do to me were they illegally
allowed to psychologically torture me in
an interrogation room well yes and no
were were they are they human beings and
is their instinct to feel confirmation
bias and to only see what they want to
see and sort of ignore disregard things
that don't go with their pre with their
prejudice like these these are all
factors that came into play and I can't
just pinpoint one reason why it happened
you know it's a lot of reasons do you
feel like that they that they started to
think that it was sexy that they had not
sexy but that it was you know there was
it was I think sex played a role but
again not just for one person because
like there's the journalist who goes
here's this like here to fresh-faced
young women and and now it's sex on like
girl-on-girl crime and that's sexy and
then on the other hand there's a you
know some police officers or prosecutors
who are looking at a crime scene and
looking at a body and seeing that there
were signs of sexual violence and so
getting this like sexuality in their
head and coming from a different culture
and a different time than I was and and
and having pre judgments about my own
sexuality or the way that my sexuality
even appeared to them because they
didn't even really know right what kind
of sexual person I was they just kind of
assumed things based on the fact that I
was an American girl right and so
there's a lot of that that goes into
play do you think that they start that
the that the police there started to
kind of get off on the attention that
they were getting at a certain point and
played into their own like almost like
they would keep up things keep up the
narrative and not and you know not veer
off and not even one of your off because
it gave them it almost romanticized
their position that's what I'm trying to
say
I think it probably had more to do with
them wanting to protect or you know they
wanted to maintain that they were
professionals with integrity and when
they're when their humanity came into
play when their prejudices came into
play when they made mistakes like many
of us admitting that they had made that
mistake like they can say like for
there's this cognitive dissonance where
they can say I'm a professional and I'm
acting with integrity and and in a
certain moment for some people like they
get on the defensive and they say that
therefore I cannot make a mistake like
how can you point to me and say like I'm
a professional with an integrity how can
you tell me that I made a mistake and
it's like well I'm sorry you made a
mistake it's okay you made money yeah
yeah but like it became an issue a
benefit can't became the blame game like
very quickly it became well whose fault
is like this is a [ __ ] up situation
whose fault it is like whose fault is it
and under what light can we cast like
how [ __ ] up the situation is because
we start with this death of a young
woman yeah and there there's no escaping
that this is a tragedy and this is this
is the story of young women throughout
history being targeted and abused and
and murdered because they're really
taken they've taken it's a matter of the
deck they have and and like and so we
start with that and then it becomes a
tragedy on top of a tragedy on top of a
tragedy and and how the focus gets
turned from one thing to another it's
being like someone that's obviously like
it like you know is dramatic and like
like I could see you being in like drama
club in school and that's what totally
wasn't drama okay so was I so I've been
in some really bad plays one time I was
in I think I was in Sherlock Holmes oh
who are you uh I was uh
Watson right great role but I changed it
to Holmes I got real like Latino the
night of this performance and I didn't
tell anybody
wait
like what's happening holes and so we
put a whole spin like my own selfish
spin on everything and and it ruined
everybody else the experience of the
night but for me it was uh you know I
just kind of took things we're a play
for yourself okay it really was even
though it was a lot of other people's uh
you know because so many people have
worked so hard for this night and then
you know it's just like me with a bad
accent kind of kind of kind of
cannibalized it shoot me was I gonna ask
you something that was good too she
seems like theater oh yeah so at a
certain point did it become a were you
able to laugh at the fact it became like
a comedy of errors or did you never even
get to that place of of like or were you
always in a place of suffering whenever
you were locked up so mm-hmm
I mean it's again a complicated answer
to that question um I when I was in
prison I realized that like my body's
sort of reset itself to a new emotional
default setting where like I you know I
was a type of person who used to wake up
in the morning and hear the birds saying
and be like yeah another day sweet and I
changed so that I woke up and I would
wake up and say another day another day
we're gonna get through this day and I'm
not gonna think about tomorrow because
if I have to think about getting through
tomorrow it's it's not I can't get
through today so I need to get through
today it's almost like a recovery
program it's almost like some minutes
I'm like 12-step recovery you know they
say one day at a time that sort of thing
yeah I accept you don't know if you're
ever gonna recover yeah because like I
had no idea when I was ever going to get
out if I was ever gonna get out um did
it did it did it feel like it paused
your ability to be like a family member
and that was the hardest part
actually I had um a moment this past
weekend I'm I'm the oldest of four
sisters and my youngest sister is 11
years younger than me and she just
turned 21 this week
and a couple things to know about that
it means that when I left she was under
ten years old
oh she was like nine years old when I
laugh she was funny too
yeah she was she was becoming a person
and um and I was gone by the time I got
back she was a young woman with her
badonkadonk and her nails and you know
like she was a young woman oh yeah they
call and I I wasn't there I didn't get
to be there for her and be her big
sister as she was moving from child to
young woman and it hit me really hard
over the weekend when like my dad was
doing her 21 run because like my dad got
like a fan and he had an itinerary we're
gonna go to like the pool hall and then
we're gonna do karaoke and all the
things I do now this yeah exactly and so
like he got us all piled us all in a van
and we all went out and I a lot of
things were going on in my mind but I
was thinking okay I didn't get a 21 run
I turned 21 in prison and that's fine
that's okay cuz I'm here for my sister
but then the reminder that like this
time had passed and she was a young one
like she was a legette young woman now
who go drinking with me now like I
missed I missed her yeah and she missed
me and I wasn't there and how did you
keep in touch how are you able to
maintain a sense of sisterhood while you
were gone so I was writing letters every
day that was how I so what I would do
are you
that's pretty empowering I bet one thing
that you can do it's the one thing yeah
and that and sit-ups but like yeah I got
really good at sit-ups but you know I
was allowed to have like a ten pictures
with me in the cell and what I would do
is I would have I would when I was
getting ready to do a letter I would
take the picture of the person that I
was going to be writing to and just
stare at it and and like it got to the
point where it's like a crazy person I
would like touch their face and like try
to feel like I was physically present
with them
and and then I would write a letter and
I would just like talk to the picture of
them and you know my little my little
assisters were a little too young to
know how to interact that way they in
writing is not their medium I'm
constantly rewriting their som but like
I'm from the past and then like but my
the oldest of my younger sisters she had
to become the big sister all of a sudden
and she would write to me asking for
advice for how to be the big sister and
that was huge that meant a lot to me I
think even more than she knows the fact
that she just asked yeah because I
wasn't there yes she takes her in the
role kind of yeah and she and she
recognized with me being gone that there
were things about being the big sister
that she didn't know that like that I
had been doing the whole time without
her realizing it and so so she grew to
have like an appreciation for me that
she didn't have before and but then you
know but then coming home what I found
is you know I thought that I was going
to go back to being the person I was and
I was gonna have the life that I had
been stolen from for a while I was just
kind of kind of go back to doing that
that's not what happened so like she's
still kind of the big sister
and I'm kind of the weird alien person
you feel like a different do you still
feel like a sister do you feel like as a
stepmom do you feel like an aunt I'm
just wondering if there's a little bit
of not reality change because obviously
these are your sisters and this is your
family yes and uh but do you feel are
you still able to being in in prison and
I say locked up I think it's pretty
though but um but does it make you feel
like did you lose can you still feel
their love as much as before do you
think it affected your ability to feel
like other people's so what it did is
before all of this happened I was very
very very close to my sisters and and in
in the kind and there's a closeness that
you get by being physically present with
someone like you just know their you
know their little you know that they
chew with their mouths open some
when they're looking at their phones and
uni and you know like you know those
little ticks that people have the way
that they paced themselves through life
that you don't get when you are at a
distance and what I found is I haven't
yet been able to reclaim that kind of
knowledge of them hmm
and nor they of me because we've we
spent developmental periods of our life
having very very different life
experiences and so we don't that we have
so much in common because we've gone
through a trauma that affected us all
but we all experienced it very
differently and I think that yeah each
person experienced it yeah so there's
there's a I mean that's the whole
tragedy of these issues is it's not just
the person at Ground Zero it's the whole
world around them that suddenly like it
sucked into this black hole of suffering
like and it seems like the part that
really affect or sounds like one of the
things that affect you the most was that
you not even that people weren't there
for you that you couldn't be there for
other people that was the hardest one
Wow yeah
yeah and and you can't like you can't
replicate time lost with someone yeah
you can't like I can't go back and be
there the first time my little sister
you know snuck out and got drunk and
needed someone to pick her up at a party
yeah like I I wasn't there
Yeah right that was my other little
sister and do they they must know how
much you care though I feel like I seem
like one of those people that it's easy
for like or they would get used to it
pretty quick Chris you could probably
know huh yeah yeah no they they do do
you feel like the is it part of it that
you don't know if you'll ever be able to
make it all the way up if that makes any
sense coming yeah you're like I love
people but they're never gonna know how
much I love them and and it's hard to
really sometimes even show how much you
really care about somebody no matter if
you what you do as a human you know yeah
sometimes I do worry that
the way that I communicate love is
potentially alien to them like you know
and I'm pretty easygoing like oh I'll go
and and like have them put the makeup on
me or do my hair or whatever like those
are nice ways that you can interact with
someone and just by spending time with
them doing something that they like like
my little sister loves makeup and so I
can I can sit there and be like do go
nuts like do Picasso on me like it's
great and I can do that and that's like
a great way to connect with her but I
I'm worried that they don't know how to
do that with me oh I see
like they don't read you different yeah
because like I'm I feel like they too
are trying to reckon with the fact that
everywhere I go there's a doppelganger
of me in the room which is the foxy
Knoxy which is the trauma which is the
infamy that which is that experience
yeah well well yeah but all the thing or
whatever you want to call it I mean I
deal with a little bit of it myself like
even just as um you know as my career is
changed in the past year you know it's
become a bigger you know it's like I'm
like my person whoever I am sometimes do
people is already there before I've got
there you know and there's nothing
sometimes it's like now I used to be
able to be myself completely one on one
and now it's like I I find I have to
like they already have a head start with
me in one direction positively or
negatively or even maybe just sideways
but they have a head start with our
interaction before I even get to them
yeah so I'm always either playing from
the hit a head or playing from behind
and just trying to make things even most
of the time I try and yeah what I feel
like I'm trying to do and I feel bad
because like a lot of times what it
means is you kind of have to have a
conversation about like the idea of you
or the idea of me that's kind of sitting
there between you and you kind of have
to deconstruct that just in order to
reach them yeah because otherwise that
you also don't feel like you're on fair
ground and I feel bad for the other
person as well because they're like well
I know you you don't know me
who does that make me like you know I
got socks so yeah like oh sorry I'm an
accused sorry to interrupt the episode I
got to tell you about this that they
have a lot of questions when you're
thinking about the internet and you are
wondering which of my online searches
does the government have a right to know
about and I definitely have thought
about that before first of all can dogs
do menthols that's one of mine obviously
you know you know Martians and BUTT
STUFF that's another one and another one
is properties where you could you know
put a body the answer none of the above
if you have expressvpn without express
VPNs protection though hackers
governments ad companies and ISPs all
have full access to your data I don't
want them using my web history or video
searches against me that's why I use
expressvpn every time I go online
expressvpn encrypts and reroutes your
web traffic to any number of countries
keeping you safer and secure expressvpn
is the fastest VPN I've tried it costs
less than seven dollars a month and
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
protect your online activity today you
don't want these Muppets getting at you
and find out how you can get three
months free at Express VPN dot-com /
Theo
that's expr e SS VPN dot-com / t heo for
three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn dot-com / Theo
to learn more protect yourself don't let
the government be knowing everything
that you're doing you have a right to
your own privacy and you have a right to
take care of yourself this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist better help is something where
say you think you
see a therapist and you're not even sure
well that's that's that's where better
help can really help you out because
it's a place you can get online and and
actually meet a therapist you can meet
them over text you can meet them over
phone you can meet them over even
FaceTime and and get a first experience
with a therapist right there it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online you can start communicating in
under 24 hours the services available
available for clients worldwide better
help is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need I remember one day I was having a
tough day and I stopped in the car on
the way here and I was driving I was
driving my car and I stopped and I said
hey I need to melt and then I got some
better help right there next thing you
know I'm chatting with some lady this
blonde haired lady therapist and she
helped me out I'm feeling better and
then my phone died actually because I
didn't have it charged up but but that
was on FaceTime better help want you to
start living a happier life today and if
you're listening today and you need some
help you can visit better help calm
slash Theo and get 10% off your first
month
that's better help.com slash th e oh and
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
that's btter h ELP dot-com slash th EO
for 10% off your first month and now
back to our episode do are there things
that you miss like I find like you know
I was uh I was in I was in the hospital
for a little bit when I was young right
a couple weeks and I was sick and and I
was scared right and my family was
scared but when I got out of there there
were still a couple things that like I
really missed about it even though it's
like a scary time or they're small
things that you miss about being
incarcerated that you didn't know but
like little things that people wouldn't
even think about I don't mean like you
know recess or anything if you guys had
that but I mean like because rarely do
you just someone get taken out of their
life for any reason I mean unless it's
getting abducted by aliens
or what happened to you or if somebody
falls in like a sinkhole or something
but there's very few opportunities to
like kind of to get pull I mean just in
a moment get taken out of your life on
this total sod path the only thing that
I can think of is I wish I had more time
to read now and I had plenty of time to
read but honestly I would never I would
never ever wish imprisonment on anyone
no it's I think sam harris asks a really
good question in his podcast where he
says like you know the worst experience
of your life you would never want to go
through it again but is there anything
that you're glad like is there is there
any part of you that is glad that you
went through it so like you wouldn't do
it again mmm I would never do that again
I would never wish it upon someone I
think that the experience of being torn
from the world and subjected to
incredibly dehumanizing treatment in the
prison system definitely gave me
perspective of the different ways that
like human beings suffer hmm that I
didn't know just because I was you know
I was also 20 I didn't you know I didn't
know who's even think who see who can
even really understand that at a large
level yeah so like I was suddenly
plunged into a very real world of human
suffering that I would again would never
wish upon anyone in like extreme ways
and but I do love reading and I don't
get to read as much as I would love
these days so that's literally be like
the brightest star that I can offer you
right now because prison sucks and like
locked up sounds cool but it's not
cool yeah it's really not and I can what
I'm sorry to like be a debbie down or to
and like kind of burst the bubble or
anything that's like it's it's really
hard to put like a nice sheen on prison
when it's really just a lot of people
who are hurting and in pain and being
and and no one cares because they're
supposed to be in pain right and and and
no one's getting better oh yeah I could
see that I could really really see that
I'm reading this book right now about
about I think it's called connections I
Joe on Hari he's at that book when we
tried to get a maybe have had them come
in and it's just talking about like they
talked about like a large woman a woman
that suffers for with obesity or eating
disorders yeah and and that the
treatment for it is all these different
diets and stuff like that and then one
time they talk about whenever they sat
down with the woman she had gotten
molested or sexually abused at a certain
time when she was young
and that's when she started eating more
so she didn't look attractive to men
mm-hmm so that if she did look
attractive to men than it would never
happen again yeah this book it's really
been it to me it's been really neat but
it's just amazing how like the
treatments that we have sometimes and I
think we're finding this out more now
because we're a little bit more
concerned with who people are on the
inside hypothetically in some ways then
it used to be probably you know 50 years
ago is just like all your bad you go to
jail you know we hang the keys over here
you know I think we're still migrating
out of that whole kind of old philosophy
yeah did you find like after being in
there in these environments did you find
that did you feel like it was effective
did you feel like it was that the system
is effective what I noticed is that the
vast majority of people who were in
there whether they were guilty or not
the vast majority of them were guilty
all of them felt like victims like they
were being a me
like they were being abused by a greater
system that and that is like you know
the justice system was being a bully
towards them like they you know they're
a lot of times impoverished a lot of
times dealing with trauma and mental
issues a lot of times you know there
aren't making great choices but they're
also saying for themselves well how many
great choices do I have like I'm human
garbage to you people and now you like
lock me up in this environment to make
me suffer even more [ __ ] you yeah like
that's a lot of things right and it
gives a whole nother chip on their
shoulder exactly and then they feel even
more justified to like break the rules
cuz they're like you don't I was like
you guys like didn't play the cards out
neatly like it's not fair it's not fair
right and so like they're they're also
victims of the unfairness of the greater
structures that led them into the prison
environment and then it's like insult to
injury to be in the prison environment
and it's tough when you have so many
people and it's all a system it's very
bureaucratic and stuff and like how do
you at that point it's really hard to
get one-on-one attention it's hard to
get really what you need it's almost
like a cattle oh is this too much feels
like that does it yeah yeah I know it's
what were the Kindle I cure conditions
like so I've never I've been only once
into a prison here in the US to visit I
was doing like a yoga behind bars I was
like trying to support this organization
called yoga behind bars which were these
women who were going into prisons and
trying to give people skills for like
dealing with trauma through meditation
or through just like body movements
because a lot of our trauma is being
held in our bodies and we don't have
access to them and so they were trying
to give them access to their bodies in
order to experience it more positively
yeah that's cool y'all do yoga with
Adriene sometimes off of the internet
Adrian you have you ever seen it I have
yeah she's just one of the first people
that comes up when you do like yoga
instructions oh yeah it's good I don't
like it it's there's all different types
but anyway yeah so so this the the
conditions that that are compared to the
US and the ones that you had in Italy
what are those
so I didn't have to wear a uniform most
of us just wore sweatpants because there
were limitations on what you could wear
but mostly we all just lived in
sweatpants 24/7 and another difference
for me and I think it again depends on
prison to prison but I was locked in my
cell for most of the day hmm
so you weren't there weren't like common
areas where people were you know working
out or going to school we didn't have
those kind of facilities so you were you
were either trapped in your room or you
were you had like your hour of outside
time in this like concrete box and it
wasn't nice out there
no it was a concrete box so with a roof
on it or a toe it did not have a roof oh
thank goodness so I could see the Sun I
could see the sky would you do you find
yourself starting to like promise pray
to the Sun like was there any like like
we did the Sun become like this
different friend that was out there I'm
just wondering ended on what side of the
prison you are on oh I'm in the sense
that like depending on if you're you're
yourself aced east or faced West the Sun
could be your best friend if you were in
the East because you got really nice
morning sunlight but if you lived in the
west side it became this excruciating
torture because like the Sun would come
in in the summer and just cook you and
like I I was it was a very happy day
when I was moved on to the east were
there people that were friendly in there
yes and again everything is complicated
right so yeah you know these questions
are kind of based in some way like I'm
just trying to like yes so I'm trying to
give a scenario right like so there yeah
and trying to see how do you say how you
stayed human in like with what other
humans certainly so there are different
kinds of relationships that you can
develop in a prison environment that are
resembling of friendly or friendship a
lot of times you try to develop some
kind of relationship like that with your
cellmate
you're trapped in a room with them I
mean you have to like problem-solve and
find solutions for how to live together
when you're two very very different
people who are living on edge
emotionally and sometimes that works and
sometimes it doesn't depending upon a
lot of factors like what is your
background
what do you how do you like to spend
your time do you like a lot of people
inside will want to just watch TV all
day and watch soap operas and like play
cards great way to spend your time
wasn't the way that I like to spend my
time I spent my time reading and some do
they think you were a nerd or anything
like that well a lot of them it was a
little worse than that some of them felt
like I was better than them yeah because
a lot of them were illiterate yeah so oh
yeah you sure book to some illiterate
people dude they're gonna think you're
Thomas Jefferson totally and like you're
showing off and like I had people who
were experiencing mental illness who
were very paranoid who like when I was
like writing letters or I was journaling
thought that I was writing about them
and because they couldn't read it they
were just convinced that it was about
them and I had someone like take my
journal and just rip it to shreds cuz
she was convinced that I was writing
about her and so it's again it's like so
different than the real world because
you you're interacting with people who
are living like animals being treated
like animals that can just get plucked
up out of their cell and move is shipped
off to another prison at any moment so
like any time like any relationship that
you might establish is also kind of a
liability because you could also have
that relationship taken away from you at
any moment and so like you have to be
careful about who you have a
relationship and why and usually it's a
utilitarian kind of relationship like oh
if I'm if I don't play cards with this
person in my cell they're going to get
mad at me and and and they're going to
gang up on me so I'm it's a it's good
for me to spend an hour of my day
playing cards with this person because I
was here he's yeah there's a lot of
keeping peace more so than like
camaraderie right
a lot of dislike mitt
what's going on making sure that was
there any is there any like dating or
dating life where there women that were
attracted to you did you have to deal
with that kind of thing in prison yes
that's definitely a thing and all but
almost thinking that would be a luxury
you know I've never been like homosexual
I don't think anyway I mean I got caught
up on some drugs one time and what
happened what this guy to go to the
airport but it was um but uh you know so
if you're wondering yeah well I'd never
hooked up with anyone but I did have
someone I have a Leica but even like
I've had friends that I like but did you
did you almost have somebody that you
loved in a way like because it was like
uh no I wasn't so lonely as that I mean
I was fortunate that I always had a
foothold outside of the prison which was
for me always the real world like I
never got was so alone that I felt like
prison was my world and it's very easy
to get to that place so I had friends
and family who were constantly riding
with me and also like love and sex were
the last things on my mind at that point
like I could have continued a
relationship with my co-defendant who
was my boyfriend before everything came
out but like as soon as we got into that
prison environment and the stakes were
so high tyndall Ike every it seemed like
the only thing that mattered was like
trying to get the truth out the last
thing that I was thinking about was like
love and sex I felt very alone
did part of this part too you died
almost a little bit like you they
disappear a little I just because that's
such a vibrant time for us in our lives
to be like just sexual and to be like
not curious but just to be alive mm-hmm
yeah so what I can say is that prior so
I was in prison for two years before I
was convicted and then I was in prison
another two years before I was acquitted
the first time and in the two years
leading up to my conviction I was
entirely asexual and then my conviction
happened and I was like holy [ __ ] I've
just been sentenced to 26 years in
prison I guess I have to
reimagine my life as being in imprisoned
life and that's actually when I taught
myself how to masturbate I didn't know
how to masturbate before then and and
was at 23 probably 22 I was 22 yeah Wow
yeah so nobody taught you in high school
or something I guess nobody gonna teach
you but I was a late bloomer
oh yeah honestly I was a late bloomer I
never really felt comfortable with my
own sexuality and and I never felt like
I was a sexual human being like a lot of
people comment about like oh foxy Knoxy
like you have this look you're like
super hyper sexual but what I don't know
if that kind of driver because I don't
know that many of the all the words that
are right but it's like what a total
opposite then yeah yeah I was not I was
not like a sexual person in high school
I was a virgin until college and even
then I was like I had to learn what an
orgasm was like it wasn't like an
obvious thing for me and I didn't have
good sexual experiences until like after
a prison really I'm sure
yeah until I well no no there was
something before her fiance who's here
he's really picked up the slack that's
what I heard it's true we do have a
really great sex life and actually we
were on the way over here my friend
Madison he was the biggest Pro yeah she
she was very nice really cool outgoing
woman yeah she's great and she sent me
this this one at one of your
conversations with a young woman named
Danielle I think who was a virgin and
then you're talking oh yeah well
yeah and then we were like oh my god
what is but if he asks you about sex and
I was like well I guess I'll just tell
them everything you know cuz like
everyone like I've gotten me I've had
someone do like the really mean way of
asking me about the whole foxy Knoxy
thing which is to be like so are you a
dominatrix like is your kink to like
hurt people like what is your [ __ ]
thing like are you the kinkiest like are
you kinky and I'm like well first of all
you're making kinky people sound like
evil people and gay people are great
yeah I mean they're up in the Ren Faire
you just have to ask the leather maker
for the other stuff but like I'm I'm
really boring I am not good at sex I you
know like so I mean I thought I was good
at it a little bit like kind of around
high school and then it's been a little
bit not downhill but it's been certainly
going off the edge of the hill since
really why I just don't like it makes me
real nervous I think a lot of times and
then it's a form of communication I have
escaped yeah so I could see that making
me nervous yeah okay well you
communicate for a living yeah barely
barely like I don't know how I got this
job sometimes but I mean I'm happy to
have it I just um but yeah I don't I I
just can't imagine like what that would
be like cuz then you're in this whole
other world everybody's like oh you're
this sexual being and you're like were
you just like am I did your whole life
see him must have seemed like almost of
like a realloc a joke or something did
it be like well it went what it ended up
becoming was it became whatever anybody
wanted it to become in order to fit the
narrative that they were pushing well in
order to make the money that they were
making and so and that continues to this
day where like someone decides that like
my existence only means this like Amanda
is a villain therefore every the
confirmation bias comes down again and
everything she does if it's if it's a
good thing that's a nice thing well
we're just going to ignore that and if
it's something that I like anything
possible to like flip and like distort
and rip out of context to
to turn into the worst possible light
like they'll do that and that's that
continues to be used to this day so
there's this like constant I'm
constantly reminded of the The Avenues
people are the actions people are taking
to see another human being like you
asking me to sit down here across from
you and you talk to me about Ren Faire
like I feel like you're trying to see me
as a person and that's so refreshing and
and like I get why my friend has a crush
on you and then like and like
communication it like yeah well
communication is sexy right like so and
it is a form of communication as a form
of sex and sex as a form of
communication so if you think of it that
way it should be easy
yeah but then like everything like the
but on the other flip side of it like it
is so so ugly when it doesn't matter who
you are or what you do or how even how
much you reach out to a human being like
they just shut down and there's a wall
of hatred that that comes from being a
puppet in their eyes like you're just a
puppet you're just an object you're
you're an idea and and you you don't get
to be treated like an like a human being
well I don't know it's so weird I don't
know if this is just me no this is makes
a lot of big sense and it actually is
into something like the media did you so
wrong and in some ways the media did me
so right like I I think that one thing
that's important is and when you say
that there what do you mean by that I
mean that you can't put the media like a
lot of people act like the media is this
like big one-eyed monster that like
stomps around the world and crushes
people with its might and it's not it's
like conglomeration of people who have
platforms right and have the ability to
analyze information or not and I think
that there was journalism that was
asking hard questions and in attempting
to unravel the like the the easy
narrative that was being pushed out
there and then there were people who
were just like oh it's such an easy
quick buck to like do a salacious
headline and just repeat that headline
when someone else wrote over in Italy
and like I don't have to think about
it's just an easy it's an easy it's a
lot it's just yeah it's a financial
thing yeah there's no yeah there's not
even a human edge to it dude but I guess
so I was thinking of his name
like is it hard to now it's like I know
you have a podcast you have a platform
and you talking a lot about justice and
your podcast I want to get the name of
it again I'll mention it at the
beginning but what is it again the truth
about true crime the truth about true
crime and true crime is I mean I watched
probably two episodes of something last
night you know and I don't even know
what it was but it's like dude I love it
you know if there's somebody if they
find some bones and they are this buried
treasure what do you love about it
count me I'm curious about this because
like I'm I was never a true crime person
until I became one the subject and so I
come at the true crime genre not as like
a fan but as someone who understands the
human consequences of true crime and so
I'm always trying to unpack the the easy
narrative that is that surrounds a lot
of these crimes that's a good question
you have a no answer right before if so
don't forget this question do you feel
like then because so many people are so
obsessed with crime with true crime with
other people's really trauma it's almost
the worst experiences of people's lives
that's that's the story right do you
feel almost like we needed someone and
not even an egotistical way do you ever
feel like we needed someone to go
through this gauntlet that you went
through to come out of it with your
perspective now because I've never even
heard someone say that I look at it from
this other perspective right because
that perspective is going could really
help change a lot of other people's the
way that we view and consume this stuff
at such a such a like crazy rate mm-hm I
can feel like a little bit that I mean I
don't know that's kind of like a fait
question where it's like oh did this
need to happen like I don't know if it
needed to happen it did happen and I
find myself constantly up again like
having a perspective that doesn't match
up with the perspective that most people
have you know like when when Epstein
killed himself in prison a lot of
people's like first sort of flippant
reaction to it was good
the [ __ ] like went after young
girls and like abused young girls and
that is all true he was a [ __ ]
but did he deserve to die in prison did
he deserve to was it is it our
responsibility now that he was in our
custody to like you know I I believe
that anyone should be allowed to kill
themselves anytime like that's that's a
different issue but like when he's in
our custody and we are responsible
towards that person we should not be
flippant about someone killing
themselves when they are in our care
it's like that's for me like I was like
that's like someone else killing
themselves like it it's not something to
be flippant about right because you
saying it reflects on our ability to so
that a prison also is a place where
there should be care is that we kind of
if we yes absolutely like these are
people who are now at our mercy mmm like
that's that's the the reality of a
prison environment is you are you have
put someone fully at the mercy of our
justice system in our society and we are
responsible for that person now and it's
not just like a good riddance like a lot
of people have that like attitude of
like good riddance through the way throw
away the key I hope he gets raped in
prison I hope that they you know kill
themselves and that's not what prison is
for and it's funny I think it's someone
was some of my thought was maybe the
well I thought that they would hopefully
find a way to learn from this guy sure
yeah I mean that was originally the
intention of prison like before before
there was prison there was dungeons
where you were kept until you actually
had the punishment that you were
supposed to get which was a corporeal
pungent punishment you had your hand cut
off you were beaten you were killed that
was the punishment for a crime and then
people came along who were like that is
just brutal we need to understand that
human beings have souls because they
were religious and they have the
opportunity to have some kind of
redemption but we have to kind of force
that Redemption on them so we're going
to remove them from society and put them
in a position of forced contemplation
and that was what the prison environment
was for but it was also like weirdly a
way of punishing people's souls instead
of their
so like the prison environment weirdly
the purpose of it was to kind of be a
soul-crushing experience for the sake of
redemption I don't know how successful
it is that redeeming like redemption
does redemption come from being soul
crushed like in my experience no in my
experience most of the people who end up
in that soul-crushing environment just
end up hating society even more and
feeling motivated to like be angry at
society and so like it's the issue of
like what do we do with people who have
done wrong as a society is really really
complicated and has to address like how
human beings really react to external
things being forced upon them and I
think the most people's reaction is just
[ __ ] those guys they're human garbage
yeah and and you know human garbage or
not they're human and they belong to our
society recyclables you're saying yeah
so yes been in there with them yeah yeah
yeah was it um was it tough Tate
probably show people how much you cared
while you were in there like if you're a
caring person I imagine you go into it
would be tough probably because it would
be hard to show some people are so you
know some people have you know done so
many bad things are in so much shame or
just filled with hatred or suffering in
different ways that it would probably be
tough but sometimes to show people that
you cared even actually it's really easy
to show someone that you care in prison
I mean though in in prison or even
outside of prison I think the thing that
to show someone that you care is if
you're present with them right now
because right now is the only thing that
matters it doesn't matter what happened
yesterday it matters what's happening
right now between you and me and I don't
care what you did yesterday can I help
you write a letter to your mom because
you can't write like I can do that I
don't care what you did right and that's
the way that I showed caring to people
is like I never asked them what crime
they did I didn't care it didn't matter
to me and it does matter in like the
greater scheme of things because like we
can't just act like crimes don't matter
right
of course but if we're talking about
like having a human like a human
connection with another person all that
matters is right now and and that is
giving that person the opportunity to be
a better version of themselves right now
not tomorrow not yesterday just right
now and that's all that matters
with the platform that you have now is
it tough to use the do you ever feel
like confused or disjointed about using
media now because like realizing the
power that it has you know after you
kind of went through a lot of you know
different pressure cookers of it or you
know it was kind of put upon you in a
lot of ways do you feel did it take some
time for you to say okay I'm gonna use
the same like airwaves and wavelengths
that kind of damaged me mm-hmm certainly
to fight my own fight for wood to me
kind of feels like justice sort of seems
to be yes very central to the whole
issue is the idea of justice does
justice exist is just as something as a
construct that we've that we've created
and that we have to agree upon is just
as a consensus is just as something
Universal how do we rep how do we enact
justice in our world like these are all
questions and I'm grappling with
everyday and you know it wasn't so much
a question for me about the the ethical
Nisour knot of like being a media person
because again I don't think of media as
this this monstrous entity it's it's a
collection of individuals and it's a
tool and you can use that tool for good
or you can use that tool for bad and I
think that I can use that tool for good
the question for me was what is that
going to cost me because every time I
put myself out there in the world it
comes with a cost
yeah there's a question like me being
here right now talking to you you know
it's not just a conversation it's an
opportunity for us to like share ideas
with people right and how people react
to those ideas is one thing how they
react to us as human beings is another
and you know I was for a long time I was
hiding like I didn't want to have to be
answerable to other people's hatred and
and and judgement that wasn't coming
from a place of judging even me was it
was judging an idea of me that had been
created not of me and so like being in
constant conversation with foxy Knoxy is
is difficult but I've realized that I do
have a different perspective that I
think is useful and at the very least is
in service of people who are suffering
who don't often get recognized as as
victims of a thing as victims of a
justice system and I try to give voice
to that I feel a responsibility
particularly because a lot of people who
go through these these issues nobody
cares
a person could have spent 20 like there
are plenty of people I know who spent
like 20 plus years in prison and no one
cares yeah and for some reason they care
about me because I like have you know
I'm a girl I don't know like it's
whatever the reasons are that people get
so mad or so interested in me is an
opportunity for me to flip that around
and go but did you know that like
there's not only is there a human being
in me but there's a whole world of
humanity that's behind the kind of
hatred that we just throw at people who
are accused of crimes and what can we do
about that so like I feel a
responsibility and I feel that media is
a very powerful tool that should be used
ethically and responsibly and I try to
do that am i successful and am i as
successful as the people who like write
really flippant headlines without doing
any research in order to just vilify the
next person no unfortunately not you
will be though you think that I really
do I think you have such a unique and
special way of like being able to first
of all thank and talk at the same time
that's a massive skill and also your
skill no really is it I don't know like
I I saw you like I was um it really is
not my skill I mean I saw you
talking to Danielle divergent and you
were just kind of there and you were
present with her yeah and like listening
is thinking like listening is fee I
think thinking and feeling often get
like separated out as if they're like
separate things but I think feelings are
information and if you're processing
your feelings your part you're thinking
you're processing information yeah and
it sounds like that's what you do with a
lot of people yeah I think I was good at
it in the beginning I think I'm still
okay with it I just have to get a little
bit more connected with myself I just
feel like kind of like lost connection a
little bit and just even in the past
like month or two out has been kind of
exhausted a little yeah there was I got
to kind of recharge my batteries and
stuff and even just thinking about
different things you know what's going
on with you I think just probably I
think I've just been burnt out yeah yeah
it was just like doing so much stuff
that I just like I was basically kind of
living my dreams and I wasn't even I
couldn't even like feel I wasn't having
like any joy
almost I was like man I'm just you know
what like I kind of had that like this
whole summer
it has just been like nose to the
grindstone like trying to tell these
stories about vigilantism for this
season the podcast right and like on the
one hand I'm having incredible
conversations with people who are like
in real moments of their lives making
decisions that take them out of the norm
like a guy who's a trucker who like goes
around and tries to expose child
predators on online and and a guy who
then puts on a mask and a cape and goes
out and like beats up people who are
bullying other people like these are
people who are taking action and their
and their vigilance and they're taking
action or making decisions and I'm
having these incredible emotional
conversations with them and then I go
back and I just like you have to just
plug and write and research and and and
just like get the work done and and it
has been draining for me too
we have to do all the work that people
didn't do for that they didn't do for
you
probably - yeah and that's that's when
and that's that is satisfying to me
because it's like I know what people
didn't do for me yeah and I don't want
to make that mistake with someone else
like I know what I needed and like the
ability to offer that to someone else is
like so so satisfying and I'm sure you
have like incredible in conversations
with people that but then you kind of
come away from them and you're like
where am I like I've just been like in
that other person's world and now I have
to get work done and I have to schedule
meetings and I have to like you know do
all of the technological work and and
like the emails the endless emails and
it feels like less meaningful than that
one thing I mean you got to get out
there like I've been telling myself I
need to go swing dancing more oh wow
yeah I mean you know I look I think it
that sounds like a nice thing this uh
Christopher swing dancer now yes we are
we're legit what do you do though what
do I like to do well it was funny
because I like doing comedy and I've
always liked it and then recently it
just became a little bit it just became
like a little bit me like I felt like I
was on a conveyor belt of my own life
and I was just kind of going and I was
like kind of there at the controls kind
of but I wasn't really like involved
almost even though I was doing
everything yeah and so now I'm trying to
take a little bit of a step back and uh
actually I got a job I'm going to do a
some work out of town for about a month
and a half and so it's gonna but it's
gonna keep me in one place and I'm just
gonna take a little bit of time Tomas a
little more time to myself
is it like a media kind of hour comedy
thing or is it like a construction job
it's a film actually it's gonna be a
movie yeah this guy this actor hit me up
personally just about a movie you know I
never really had any intentions of doing
anything like that mm-hmm
but this guy like literally like three
people in the world maybe could have
asked me and I feel like this guy maybe
was one of them so I'm gonna try it out
and also I think part of me just needs a
new experience it's not even like a big
role I was gonna say I like it I need
something to kind of just just kind of
remind me that of what's going on you
know just a little change of pace but
also that like life can be different
like that's the other thing that I think
new experiences are so important about
is like we kind of all sort of dig our
own trench and then we forget that like
life could be a different way and like I
always have this like weird little
fantasy in the back of my head of like
disappearing into like the mountains and
making cuckoo clocks yeah and that's
like my weird little fantasy is when I
feel like too stuck and I'm like I'm
just too stuck in this
back in life that I'm in like I'm like
or I could just go and like be a troll
in the mountains and make that could
also be my life I think when you look
back at your well how you when you
originally got incarcerated do you see
how like like you don't seem like
somebody that would ever kill someone
you don't even seem like somebody that
would probably I could see you maybe
trying you know drawn up some fireflies
overnight honestly you know fireflies
you know what is that what are those
things like lightning bugs like jarring
them up I could see in the poor things
like sleep aw yeah it was an accident
you know you're gonna kill a couple of
them you know I'm saying you had all
good intentions you just wanted like a
little night like that you could carry
with you to the restroom I could see it
would be magical yes but do you see when
people were like do you see like that
just but I could see how people would
look at you and think like oh maybe you
know she's whimsical er did you see
looking back like oh maybe I could see
were you able to even recognize like oh
I see how people looked at me and maybe
the face I'll wake or the may make or
the way I smile or my sense of humor or
what I think is is fun or and they could
you see how they transpose that or did
you think that they just it was mostly
just malicious I mean I think that most
of it was some something that people
were projecting on to me and I was a
convenient canvas for that because
nobody knew who I was right like I was a
nobody and so that meant that I could be
in anybody and then once people decided
what that person was like having that be
corrected like you know yes you you see
me right now I'm this is how I am and I
honestly feel like a lot of the negative
things that people have felt about me
have been a projection of their some
something some kind of like nightmarish
imagination that they have they've just
projected on to me because again it's
like a confirmation bias you see what
you want to see and if you want to see
like someone could look at me right now
and say oh I'm sitting here
I'm daring to sit here like talk talking
to someone as if like I am NOT a [ __ ]
murderer and like me I'm just constant
like just my very like a lot of people
feel that my very existence is an
affront to Meredith's memory and that
like the very fact that people even know
my name and know that I exist is an
offense that I am that I am committing
against Meredith's family and so like
when my own just existence is a problem
like anything can be a problem right so
Oh must be system is it sometimes a
battle to get going every day in some
ways like our is it like or just some
days it just kind of you kind of have
moments where it just you forget that
not forget but I never forget I don't
think I'll ever forget but my life is
not just what other people think of me
yeah fact the majority of my life is not
that the majority of my life is who I
love and and and what what work I'm
doing because I love the work that I'm
doing it's the question of now what and
and the the beautiful thing about my
life right now is I'm asked that
question and I suppose that question
never fully went away even in prison I
was thinking well I guess this is my
life I didn't think this was going to be
in my life but how do I like how do I
live my best life and so brave I don't
know I mean it's that or kill yourself
like that's it really
what did you like I just wonder
sometimes I guess a lot of us always I
guess here's a lot of people wonder if
they went to prison who they would be oh
sure
one thing okay here's something that's
like really sad I thought that I have
can like I feel like I'm such a right
I don't think so okay so okay I worry
that I wouldn't be a great person if it
weren't for everything that I went
through like I would be an okay person
I've always been a nice person I've
always like rooted for the underdog and
I did you know I was you know doing
musicals and I would probably still be
going to run fairs but like I and that
makes you a good person I think it helps
a little yeah like you know before all
this happened I didn't know about what
poverty and mental illness looked like
and how that affected people and I
didn't know what the justice system was
doing to people and I did never was on
my radar you never would have known I
never would have known and so like I
think that I would have lived a much
more clueless existence but I hope not I
hope that like I would have had other
experiences that would have allowed me
to grow it's hard to say though I hate
playing the what if game because on the
one hand like I do think about I wasn't
there and I wasn't there when my sister
turned like turned into a teenager and I
wasn't there to see her like I wasn't
there to like go and get her training
bra with her I wasn't there and that
means that and I'm never gonna get that
back but on the other hand like I've I
got a crash course in humanity and I
feel like I've done a lot of hard work
to absorb meaning and compassion from
all of that and I'm proud of that and I
want to share that with people and I and
I think that's a good thing yeah yeah it
seems um Hannah it's just it's such us
there's so much like I guess kind of
like forgiveness in your story sort of
or not forgiveness but just it's like
you didn't even kind of take that route
of like blame and yeah forgiveness and
I'm like well I don't even feel like
I've other like just your perception of
it all do you feel like do you relate to
different characters now like villains
whenever you see stuff on television do
you relate to more like Jessica Rabbit
or Cruella de
she was trouble but she was also just
had you know Roger rabbit's back the
whole time yeah like sweet i i've been
compared to jessica rabbit before which
is hilarious to me but but from the I'm
not bad I'm just drawn that way kind of
way and so people have used that on me
before I don't relate to karela de Ville
because I love animals right but get me
in a room with Cruella de Vil and I
think that I could uncover things about
her that that III kind of pride myself
on being willing to speak to anyone I
talk to anyone I've lived with people
who killed their own children so like I
can I feel comfortable speaking to
someone and being willing to like be
present with them again like it's not
like I who you are right now is a
product of all of the things that came
before you but I'm interested in the
things that that's happening right now
and there could be something blossoming
right now that's like a humanitarian
almost I mean that's a thing I I just I
want I want to give everyone the
opportunity to be a human being and and
to grow and and to be different and to
then what my expectation is going to be
I'm really open to that I'd and I don't
think that makes me gullible or or or
silly because I can tell when I've
definitely had encounters with people
who are very dangerous and who hurt me
and I've learned from those experiences
from allowing myself to open up to
people who were hurtful to me what makes
you hopeful I think which is something
that's very nice to have you know and
someone has to be that mm-hmm
yeah and I think that everyone is sort
of motivated not out of like evil
intentions but out of a when people do
things that are wrong it's because they
misunderstand how what they're going to
do there they misunderstand where their
motivations are coming from and they
misunderstand their effect on people or
I guess
I mean there are some people who are
just [ __ ] like beating people up and
and raping people and killing people and
they know what they're doing but a lot
of times they come from a place of
feeling entitled or justified and like
to unpack where they how they feel how
they got to that place of feeling
justified and entitled enough to an act
of violence on another human being is
yeah that's where we can solve things
that's where we could solve Italy
almost everything it feels like yeah it
feels like yes I'm fighting the RO yeah
where it's not enough for me to like
point out oh you did this because you
were feeling entitled like you're an
entitled [ __ ] it's me I want to let
go and be like but how did you get that
right how do you get there yeah I don't
ask oh that's so interesting yeah it's
funny it's like um yeah the people
aren't the in the end of it all yet
people aren't the problem and it's it's
it's whatever has caused us just to
behave these ways is is is the problem
you know and yeah sometimes you wonder
if it's defeatable or not but the only
thing that makes you feel good is
they're trying to fight is to try and
fight it yeah and and I think to try to
see it right because I think that a lot
of people don't want to like look that
far down because they feel like it's
justifying bad behavior but I don't
think understanding bad behavior means
you're justifying it interesting I I
think that yeah because I sometimes have
wondered what we've been speaking like
okay is she just trying to justify that
people behave badly like in these
systems and stuff but now I want to see
what you're saying about having an
understanding of it because then if you
can you can help them understand it too
yeah cuz man imagine what it feels like
probably to have killed someone and not
even have any clue why yeah and then
that's how you're just totally yeah and
like I've talked to women I've talked to
women who killed their kids because they
were feeling postpartum depression and
they then they didn't have a good
support system around them and they just
felt like they they were have they had a
breakdown they had a mental breakdown of
like I can't handle my own life and the
only thing that I know to
right now in this like I'm trapped in my
life is to put my baby in a garbage can
I can't like I can't think of anything
else to do and and that I've talked to
that person and she feels terrible for
what she did and she can never escape it
and she constantly feels like she's
falling in black holes and like and can
never get out of it but like you know I
understand that she felt like how she
felt when she did that bad thing and
empowering people with understanding is
is uh there's there is something
empowering about that and empowering
them to like get out of that place
is also good like I think that right now
there's there's this kind of movement
for sort of like defining people as one
thing and then saying you are that thing
and you will be that thing forever and
like [ __ ] you and that's not how human
beings work but that's changing though I
think like even did you see Joe Rogan
interview Bernie Sanders do you have oh
no I didn't see that no and whatever
thoughts your own politics are not you
know and I don't talk much about
politics but but it was just interesting
to see a long-form conversation with a
politician it just gave you a diff it
gave you way different ideas of who that
man was kind of as a person instead of
sound bites yes instead of sound bites
it was it was really fascinating I
thought that you think Nick yeah it was
great yeah they need more that he's done
it with Telsey got Gabbar to if every
single candidate could do it I think
we'd be all be more informed yeah we
would be better off so I think yeah I
think especially through Pollak a past
podcasting and stuff that the the the
hope that you're talking about I think
it's growing mm-hmm you know I really
like there ya know talk about it a lot
on the I really think it's growing I
mean especially thing with Rogen and
talking to Bernie Sanders I think it's
gonna change the entire landscape of
like how people accept other how they
learn who a person is yeah so I think
and you yeah you seem like you're gonna
be like like like a coat like a coat
like a operative like a black ops
professional on like you just so you're
very great at communicating with people
Thanks yeah it's a great skill I'm
sitting here the whole time wishing that
I was you instead of me just because
you're just better at talking and it's
like or it's just more organized what uh
I have this question for you so you are
you haven't you've been inked you've
been engaged now and you guys have a how
does that go you guys had such the wild
engagement the media or landed mm-hmm a
meteor of love yes and uh which is
really cool kind of reminded me of like
chivalry and like oh it's I reminded me
when I was in junior high dude I had
acne bruh I mean I had a low my god I
had the most acne remember how I never
got laid in high school yeah smile and
someone like me would like bus it was
just like pain I just had like those
like ones like the deep a deep pain it's
like it's like as deep as my shame like
that's how deep my acne was deep anger
that's a rock in your face it's so bad
but at that time I walked across the
basketball court in like I got on my
knee and I gave a rose to some girl like
you know and she had some real thighs on
her brow but she was really she was
really beautiful when uh so anyway the
best of us have yeah like a Down
syndrome girl but um and no offense
anybody has Down syndrome either but um
but anyway it just kind of reminded me
of that it was like oh here's some nice
chivalry going on well the gesture right
like yes that somebody took time that he
that he thought in advance yeah what
what are some things that uh that
attracted you to your current fiancee oh
that's a great question thank you for
asking well I know he cared enough to
come with you I don't think it's you
know I think yeah and I'm curious as to
like how are you were able to like yeah
I guess how someone like you like looks
how they accept like you know people
other people's care or how they notice
it you know mm-hmm well one of the
wonderful special things about Chris is
when I first met him he did not Google
me he didn't really know much about the
case
and actually maybe I should just give
you our origin story do you want our
origin I'll take it yeah yeah after the
meteor I need a name I need like
superheroes began so our origin story is
that I was doing local arts
correspondence for a local newspaper
under a pseudonym around like 2015 and I
was I was doing arts correspondent so I
was going to plays writing reviews doing
all that kind of thing and I was given
this a debut novel by these two
novelists and I read it and it was
hilarious and heartbreaking and I
laughed and I cried and was so smart
and so I wrote this rave review
submitted it to the paper and I was
gonna be the end of it except the very
next day I walked out of my apartment
building and across the street in like
the diner window was like a concert
poster before a book reading for this
book that I had just read and I was like
that's coinkidink like I never go out
but maybe I'll go to this book reading
so I did and when I got well you you
feel susceptible to a poster for a book
reading yes I did and before remember
I'm a nerd yeah so no I wonder I wonder
who falls to set one of those posters
and now and so I went and what I
witnessed was these two guys one of them
is this like big bald military guy with
a lisp and his best friend who had like
stripes carved into his beard and like
Elton John t-shirt and like glasses and
it was the most beautiful bromance I had
ever seen see that and I asked him for
an interview so they invited me over to
Chris's house and we did an interview
but that kind of devolved into drinking
scotch and watching Star Trek and like
meandering out into the like
neighborhood throughout the evening just
kind of like shenanigans and at the end
of that
Gavin his best friend this military guy
gave me this big bear hug and Chris
reached out and was like and to shake my
hand and said we should be friends
mhm and you know that's a throwaway kind
of thing except like this came a month
after I was fully exonerated
and it was the first time I thought oh I
can make friends in the real world like
a real person and so they became like my
first friends after I was fully
exonerated and you know life went on and
a friendship will escalate
yeah friendship will escalate and so
nine months later we we started hooking
up and dating and you know poor Chris
like he has to you know his relationship
has been with me but it's also kind of
been with that like doppelganger version
of me in the room like my trauma is an
ever-present part of my life little
anecdotes about like Oh have you seen
wall-e and I was like when did it come
out because I was probably you can't
even play [ __ ] marry kill at all without
somebody being like do people say that
all the time all the time it's me Casey
Anthony and who's the other one in [ __ ]
marry kill it's another person and Jodi
arias but do people say things to you
all the time they're like oh man I
didn't even realize that I can't say
that like it must does that happen
sometimes you're not oh no I I am super
accommodating and have a sense of humor
about the whole thing I'm I'm not that
you're like oh right you know but like I
I understand when people are in a space
where it's just like I can't laugh about
that I don't know I did have I did have
one comedian make a joke about me once
and it came at her just a really bad
time like it came on the heels of him
meeting me in a very different
environment he was actually interviewing
Chris about his book hmm and he didn't
know it was me and I just kind of
happened to be there I was like I was
doing some cross stitch in the you're
like in the 1700 but it was like it was
a Super Mario cross stitch so Super
Mario cross stitched in the corner and
this is so like this guy doesn't really
notice me and it's only after the
interview after we left that he realized
it was me and you know six months go by
and my little sister for her birthday
wants to go out to see this
median and so we all go out we all get
dressed up like all the girls doing the
girlie thing and going out to see this
comedian that she likes and the opener
for this comedian is this other guy who
met me six months ago but didn't realize
who I was and he starts out his bed with
you know you know how like you don't
know when there's like a famous person
in the room with you until after they've
left and then he goes on on the shtick
where he's like man you can't like leave
me in a room with a man and knock she'll
kill me with her knitting needles and it
was just not a good joke right like it
was it wasn't a good joke but it was it
was also just it hurt because like on
the one hand my little sister was like
it's my little sister's birthday and
suddenly my name gets dropped like it's
suddenly everyone's like the focus is on
me and there's like Amanda is she gonna
be okay like they're talking about her
they're making jokes about her killing
people with knitting needles and so on
the one hand ups it upset me because it
took us out of like my sister's birthday
and on the other hand it upset me
because it's like this guy met me and I
was like you didn't you I was just being
me I was doing Super Mario cross-stitch
in the corner and he felt like the joke
to make about that situation was she'll
kill me with knitting needles and it's
like that is so easy and so mean I don't
know it just it did it felt like you
know like I expect it when people don't
know me and haven't met me in person to
like make jokes at my expense
because they just don't think I'm a
human being and I wasn't expecting like
the person who it would be like if you
went out and did a comedy thing after
like having this conversation and it was
like oh I you know I yeah you're
villains or yeah yeah well if you made a
joke about like you know about me
killing you in the room or something
like that's it's not a good joke like if
you want to make a joke like I I'm fine
with the people making jokes about me
but like big make them be good
yeah yeah everyone will think I'm guilty
like and like the joke that I say around
everyone this is like you're not allowed
to die around me I don't care what you
did like I'm like if someone give that
guy a hymen maneuver because I can't do
one like I can't like deal with this
believe me even yeah you only give one
get out of jail in four years card I
guess so
so you and christen see you guys have a
wedding date set yet yeah February 29th
which is leap day no and I know but even
better and this is like the best so like
we took so we took like the the the kind
of crystal of that first thing and we
were like and I was referencing a video
you guys don't know I was referencing a
video on YouTube that you can see of
their proposal yeah so Chris basically
made a meteorite fall and crash land in
my backyard and inside the meteorite
wasn't just like a ring it was a broken
data crystal from the future
encyclopedia Galactica
that was like Wikipedia of our future
together and he was like wow I guess we
have a future together I guess that
means do I like ask you now I guess it's
really happening now will you marry me
and like that was like the the the game
was like oh the future says that I
proposed to you right now so I guess I
have to propose to you right now and so
what we've done is we've built a story
around that where the data crystal came
rocketing back in time because us in the
future went to the Encyclopedia
Galactica and looked ourselves up and
baroque our time stream so our time
stream has been broken and now we we're
only hypothetical Amanda and Chris
getting married and unless everyone we
love comes together into one bubble
outside of space and time and knits our
time stream together then we don't exist
anymore so it's still knitting them or
knitting it yeah wow that's cool yeah
it's uh it's really cute and it's just
yeah it's still um yeah it's like a lot
of
believe you know it's cool though we
like to I love to play yeah dancing is
playing getting dressed up in costumes
is playing you've always been like that
I've always loved to play and music is
playful like if you're singing and
playing music together that's play
because you can like you never know what
the next person is gonna happen and you
just kind of like bounce off of them I
love play and I love kind of like
getting people out of their shells to
play with me and I think that if you
give people an excuse to put on a
costume they'll do it but they need an
excuse I don't need an excuse I'll put
on a costume at any time but like a lot
of the people I love need an excuse and
so it's not gonna be Halloween it's
gonna be February 29th it's gonna be a
wedding yeah wow it's beautiful
congratulations on on so much going on
your life um you know I texted two that
got pain Lindsay do you know he is he
does yeah I love pain Lindsay he's great
yeah I was gonna try to connect you guys
I don't know if maybe if you have been
connecting him yes we ran into each
other at a true-crime convention cool of
course no I was just thinking a few
minutes ago I was like I wonder who
maybe if she was gonna you know have a
guess or or he's actually invited me to
be on one of his new podcasts so I think
it's supposed to I think everyone's
supposed to be anonymous so maybe I just
ruined it oh no it's like
congratulations thanks so much for
coming in you have any other questions
Nick did some come in from the viewers
who recover it oh we have a couple
patreon but I was wondering like how
familiar you are with some of the really
big true crime stories like serial and
making a murder and if you see any like
parallels with your case in them or if
you have specific like you think they
did it or didn't do it those instances I
know love those didn't I yeah I'm aware
of both those cases so Adnan Syed and
Brendan Dassey so I am good friends with
one of brendan dassey's attorneys who's
an expert in false confessions I think
that there's a flagrant abuse of his
rights he was he was forced to falsely
confess and that is the only evidence
they used to convict him it's obscene
that his
that his conviction wasn't overturned
obscene that he's in there it's obscene
that he's in there and um you know
Steven Avery I is a the question is a
little more complicated and I don't know
the facts of his case as well but I know
I know also through my friend that
Brendan Dassey it's just ludicrous and
he needs to get out of prison now and
anything anyone can do to help matters
and like one of the things that I'm
trying to do to help in my own way is
just try to wait raise awareness of
false confessions and coercive
interrogation techniques and how police
once again like in these environments
you know people think that if you make a
false confession or a false admission or
a false accusation like that it's coming
from you when in fact it's like the
police are authoring a narrative and you
have to just sign on and like they bully
you and psychologically torture you
until you can't take it anymore and
you're willing to sign on to anything
just to make it stop oh I can imagine
four or five hours of torture and that's
no it's so it's it's ya know like and
Brendan Dassey was so young and he like
he was he was O'Brien are so
impressionable they like put him through
it for days and days and days it's just
it's ridiculous what happened to him
none Syed I think there is I signed
alongside a number of my exoneree
buddies we all signed a petition in
order to get his case relooked at so you
know like when you say that do you mean
that he is that you believe that he's
innocent or you just think that he
should be the tree looked at he deserves
to have a new trial I don't think that
the evidence that was used to convict
him was sufficient to find guilt and you
know I I think that it's it's only fair
that someone is actually put through a
justice process based on evidence that
makes sense and it's only then that we
can all determine that I would love to
sit on a jury one day yeah but no one's
ever gonna put me on a jury like no
one's ever gonna put me on a jury and I
would love to be on that jury maybe what
if you knit a nice disguise I bet you
here you are because yeah I may be a
good juror
you know I think you know probably a lot
of beat of a lot of questions probably
but I bet it would be good
Oh certainly and I mean and you know I
come from it from an experience but that
doesn't mean that I'm like biased
towards innocence or guilt or anything
like I what it what I am biased about is
like I know how [ __ ] up the system can
be Amanda Dufresne do you have anything
else Johnny uh all the patreon we pretty
much answered but I just had one
question like what was your day like
when you found out that you were
reconvicted you were in the u.s. she's
just like roll over to a tax match feel
like [ __ ] right just curious
oh god the build-up to that was really
hard it wasn't like oh yeah there was I
think the thing the more shocking moment
for me was actually when the Supreme
Court in Italy overturned my first
acquittal I was not expecting that and
so that was a phone call from my lawyer
to say to give me the bad news and to
let me know that I had to go through yet
another trial because it wasn't just
like you know an overturn of an
acquittal it means they sent me back to
be retried again and so I was retried
again in absentia
they found me guilty and from and yeah
and so again I have that phone call with
my lawyer who tells me we're gonna fight
it but I didn't know what that meant
like I suddenly had to start thinking
about what extradition looked like and
how I was going to if Italy decided to
you know if the Supreme Court in Italy
was going to confirm that conviction how
I was going to turn myself in to the
local authorities and make a case for at
the very least serving my time in the
u.s. so that my family wasn't such a
burden on my family I I was living yes a
lot of people like think you know four
years in prison but it was really eight
years of
of waiting to know if I was allowed to
live again yeah so Wow
what up her I mean just what a purgatory
for like your growth and for your
humanity yeah my 20s were this yeah
and I'm only 32 now so it's weird like
I'm I'm weirdly very very young in the
real world which means that I'm like
stumbling around and trying to like
figure out what being a real a real
person is like when it's not much left
to be in a real person so yeah then in
other ways I think we might be on a
horizon of realizing the value of
humanity again in some ways and that's
what I hope a lot of times yeah well I
love what you're doing because it sounds
like you're coming from this like
optimistic place of like if I just sit
with someone will will just be humans
together isn't that great did everyone
forget how cool that is
and like I love that that's that's a
that's a really really useful thing to
do yeah so we try our best you know
we've learned we learn as we go in here
you know yeah we definitely try our best
have you had thank you for saying that
yeah have you had any contact with
Meredith's family this is another
question I get a lot of the answer to
that question is once again it's
complicated I've I've written and sent a
letter than many years back but what I
have what I have heard from their lawyer
and in general is that they are not in a
in a place to want to talk to them like
in the in these situations you have
people who have gone through a terrible
trauma and they have an experience of me
that like just the very being of me is a
trigger for that trauma yeah might just
remind them of it and there's nothing
wrong with that or anything and so like
when it comes to the Kircher family I
firmly believe that like they have like
if I it's not my position to force
myself on them to be understood by them
if and when they want to have a
relationship with me I'm ready
and I'm I'm I'm ready to answer every
hard question that they might have I do
think this is a this is a whole thing
about restaurateurs justice right it's
like coming to see how like how how a
crime Meredith's murder has impacted so
many people and like finding that common
ground and finding a reconciliation and
understanding but like you have to be
ready and willing to like come to the
table with that goal in mind and until
that happens like I can't force myself
on them yeah it's funny a lot of times
in my own like issues and stuff if I'm
not like I want to do something I'm not
ready I'll pray for like willingness you
know yeah like I'll pray for like the
step before the capability you know it's
like just you know may God make me
willing to do this because I want to I'm
having trouble getting to you action
yeah that's the biggest like I think
that's the biggest challenges like a lot
of people like they could do it if only
they could like bring themselves to do
it yeah you know did you uh did you have
faith you struggle with faith did that
come in here in your sentence at any
point like when you were by yourself or
when you were in prison
mmm so I am an atheist and no it's okay
everybody has their own experience with
I am very hopeful that I'll try my best
have faith you know okay
and yeah that's that's cool yeah I'm
soldiers yours is okay it's it's okay a
little moan thoughts it's probably
somehow project him own stuff yeah I
wonder like what atheist like what eight
that word means to you because I I
clearly do a lot of clearly I guess
maybe not clearly I'm I do a lot of
self-reflection reflection I do a lot of
meditation I do a lot of thinking about
my place in the world and my impact on
on people in the world and those are all
things that really they're really
important to me and one thing that's
also really important to me is like one
thing that's
real to me is that I can't rely on the
universe to like be good right right
like for me there is no like the
universe is good or bad it's not any of
those things all it is is existence
existence is what it is it's neutral and
we happen to be conscious and we are we
have concepts of like what what makes
something good or bad like human
suffering bad bad for me bad for you bad
for everyone we know that that's bad
yeah but it's not because it's
inherently bad it's not because someone
decided or decreed that it was bad or
that the dogma decreed that it was bad
is just that's how we experience things
right we know it's bad we know it's bad
and we don't want that to happen to
someone we wouldn't want it we wouldn't
wish it upon ourselves and like so when
I'm finding when I'm trying to find you
know guidance or or when I'm looking for
that willingness to do something it's
it's motivated with the understanding
that like the only thing that can make
the only thing I can do in my life small
'no sand aloneness is try to like make
connections with human beings and try to
bring try to like make as less suffering
as possible and as much like joy and
growth as possible and and i have to
find that in myself and I know that like
no one's riding me no one's like telling
me to do that it's really just me me in
my head alone figuring that out for
myself and that's a responsibility that
I have to take you know I feel
responsible because I'm aware of myself
right and being aware of myself is like
the first thing that I have to do as a
conscious being yeah and it's still it's
a fight for good it's like we're on this
it's as equal there's no judgement from
the universe against us you're saying
and it's but we do know right from wrong
we do know how it feels anyway yeah and
on and on our human scale it's important
it's important but in the big grand
scheme of things it's not but for us it
is and like just because something in
the big grand scheme of things is
utterly meaningless doesn't mean that it
isn't meaningful to us right now because
this is the level that we live on right
we don't live on cosmic levels right
right we don't live kind of yeah there's
not this eternal this it's right now
yeah right now well I think that one
thing that's dad I mean I certainly
agree that it's like yeah we I think
that good is infectious you know okay
yeah so it's like yeah like that it's a
battle yet it is a battle it's like I
can choose to battle for good or to not
you know I think one thing that I would
push back on that
mmm-hmm is I don't like the term battle
okay because battle means that there's
an enemy and like I think that it's very
very easy to fall into this mindset when
you have an enemy that you then find a
target to to be the like the object of
your enemy whereas for me I look at it
as you're building something you're
creating something we're always creating
something and what are you creating what
do you what do you put what energy are
you putting into it it's going to exist
in the world and you're creating it what
is it going to do and I will say this I
will my last move will be that you would
know that from personal experience
a lot better than I would how that you
know how when somebody when there's a
lot of you know energy that it can be
targeted at someone mm-hmm so yeah it's
like kind of like that blame or
forgiveness thing it's like I'm not even
that's not even like what I'm thinking
about I'm thinking about like what am i
putting out into the world and and what
is its impact you have to drop it a
notion like what does that ripple effect
yeah so I think we I think we certainly
agree on that my last question is how
much did the whole that it all cost
it must I can't even imagine the cost of
all the attorneys and everything I don't
even I could not even tell you how much
it cost because it cost that much like I
my my what my family paid what I've had
to pay what I'm continuing to have to
pay and for something that's not even
your fault no wow that's a lot of power
it's a lot of power to stand up in the
face of all those different things and
to you know to
you know be someone who still wants to
help others you know or store just once
I don't know it's impressive and it's
very interesting
it helps me yeah I mean like I can't say
that like me helping others doesn't help
me because right along the way I'm
finding meaning yeah like I'm having
that connection and so as much as that
person is having that connection with me
I'm having that connection with that
person
tell me like 3 things that you really
love about Chris and then what we don't
know yeah because you're like taking
notes and I think it's very sweet that
he's just impatient and been here I
don't want to feel a part of it so so I
read things that are things that I love
about Chris yeah Chris is willing to
confront what he's afraid of
um chris is a excellent communicator and
they're gonna say chef sorry well he
also is an excellent chef like yeah but
he's an excellent communication is
really important to me and I think that
like communication hasn't really been
one of those things that the grander
culture has instilled in in in boys it's
not something that like we hold up as
something that's very important for
young men is to have like an emotional
intelligence that they are able to
communicate young girls are like from a
very young age we're taught to like get
up in each other's business and be like
oh do you have a crush on this guy well
why do you have a Christian that guy
like and that is like brute practicing
emotional intelligence and it's less so
something that young men are encouraged
to do but like he is very very
emotionally intelligent and very good at
communicating when like he understands
that I experienced the world sometimes I
experience the world and I experience
emotions in a different way than he does
but he doesn't hold that against me he
understands I'm like I just experienced
the world as I do he experiences the
world as he does and we both appreciate
those differences like for instance a
really good example Chris looks at boobs
and he can't stop looking at boobs you
know like he just like looks at manic
he looks at like he looks at anything
that remotely resembles a boob and he's
kinda can't help himself like he just
kind of gets distracted and it's you
know it's like so real and like it's
something that I like I don't have a
comparison it's not like I look at like
guys shoulders and go I'm so distracted
right now like I just don't experience
that but I appreciate that he's able to
communicate with me what that's like and
I can communicate something on the ad
right because otherwise guys are
sneaking around the mall trying to hide
behind a plan and yeah and you don't
deal with them and then that's it yeah
and like I kind of like now now that I'm
in on it
yeah like we're kind of in on it
together and I'm like looking at that
and he's like yeah and I'm like okay so
I see you like I'll be over here knit in
a cloak I'm Amanda what's your middle
name
Marie Amanda Marie Knox thanks for being
here today and people can check out your
podcast the truth about true crimes
that's right
right and yeah thank you so much really
appreciate of course thank you yeah
[Music]
when I reach that round I'll share this
piece of mind I can feel it enough
thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself fall my
[Music]